nosotros ya hemos visto a qué nos
referimos cuando estamos tratando de
sacar 64 elevado a la potencia un tercio
aunque y esto lo que significa es
simplemente que tenemos que encontrar la
raíz cúbica del número 64 ok o sea
tenemos que encontrar un número que si
lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 3 veces
nos da 64 ahora por otro lado nosotros
sabemos que si tomamos el 4 y lo
multiplicamos por sí mismo tres veces o
sea multiplicamos cuatro por cuatro por
cuatro
o sea elevamos el 4 a la tercera
potencia lo que obtenemos es 4 por 4 16
por 4 64 entonces esto nos dice que 4 es
justo ese número que si lo multiplicamos
por si mismo tres veces tres veces nos
da 64 así es que esta raíz cúbica de 64
es igual a 4 o sea 64
un tercio es 4 ahora lo que vamos a
hacer ahorita es hacer esto mismo pero
un poquito más complicado aunque con
exponentes más complejos aquí este
exponente es una fracción pero su
numerador es un 1 y eso es justo lo que
vamos a cambiar
ok ahora nos interesa saber qué pasa
cuando queremos encontrar 64 elevado a
la potencia dos tercios aunque y para
hacer eso vamos a usar una propiedad de
los exponentes que vamos a ver más a
fondo más adelante pero que podemos ver
rápidamente ahorita digamos con un
número sencillo pongamos por ejemplo un
2 que tenemos aquí el 2 y digamos que
tenemos elevado este 2 a la potencia 3 y
después todo este nuevo número que es 2
a la 33 8 lo tenemos elevado a la
potencia 4 aunque ya hay una propiedad
de los exponentes que nos dice que
este número completo es igual a tomar la
base que es este número 2 y elevarlo a
la potencia 3
por 4 3 por 4 es 12 entonces esto es
igual a tomar el 2 y elevarlo a la
potencia 12 aquí tenemos un número ese
número lo estamos elevando a la potencia
3 y luego todo ese número te lo estamos
elevando a la potencia 4 y eso es
exactamente igual a tomar ese número que
es el 2 y elevarlo a la potencia de esta
potencia por esta potencia o sea 3 por 4
que es 12 bueno pero esto lo podemos ver
también como 2 elevado a la potencia 4
por 3 y esto lo podemos ver cómo hacer
digamos lo inverso a lo que hicimos aquí
esto lo podemos ver como 2 elevado a la
4 y todo eso elevado a la 3 y bueno
justo esto es lo que queremos usar por
acá porque dos tercios lo podemos ver
como un tercio multiplicado por dos no
entonces esto de aquí lo podemos ver
como 64 elevado a la potencia un tercio
y después todo esto elevado al cuadrado
porque me a 64 elevado a la un tercio y
después al cuadrado es igual a 64
elevado a la un tercio por 2 y eso es
exactamente igual a 64 elevado a las dos
tercios entonces estas dos cosas son
iguales pero nosotros ya sabemos cuánto
vale 64 elevado a la un tercio lo
tenemos por aquí aunque entonces 64
elevado a las dos tercios es 64 elevado
a la un tercio que es como vimos por
aquí 44 esto es igual a 4 y después
tenemos que elevarlo al cuadrado al
cuadrado
grace 64 a la dos tercios es 4 al
cuadrado que es 4 por 4 10
y 6 ahora como yo lo pienso es tal cual
tengo aquí la expresión 64 a la dos
tercios y yo sin tener que escribir todo
esto simplemente digo 64
vamos a tomar primero la raíz cúbica
raíz cúbica de 64 es 4 y después
elevamos al cuadrado entonces 4 al
cuadrado es 16 y listo
bueno vamos con otro problema este
problema te recomiendo que lo hagas tú
solito y ya después cheques lo que
hicimos nosotros como solución y voy a
tratar de ponerle colores bonitos
entonces a ver 8 entre 27
elevado a la menos dos tercios ok
así es que ya sabes ponle pausa hazlo tú
en tu cuaderno y luego lo pones play
bueno vamos a resolverlo paso a paso
aquí para hacer esto lo primero que hago
es fijarme en el signo del exponente
aquí tenemos un menos y esto lo que nos
dice es que tomemos el recíproco de la
base aunque ello sea tomemos 1 entre 8
entre 27 y eso lo único que hace es
cambiar el numerador con el denominador
osea que aquí nos queda 27 entre 8 y el
exponente lo dejamos tal cual pero en su
forma positiva aunque ya no va a ser
menos dos tercios va a ser simplemente
dos tercios así es que aquí nos queda
elevado a la potencia dos tercios y como
lo vamos a hacer para resolver esto
pues vamos a usar una propiedad de los
exponentes super importantes que ya
vimos que lo que nos dice es que si
tenemos una fracción elevada a otro
exponente eso es igual a tomar el
numerador 27 y elevarlo al exponente o
sea elevar 27 a la dos tercios y
dividirlo entre el denominador
denominador elevado a la misma potencia
o sea elevarlo a la dos tercios bueno
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es ver
qué significan cada una de estas
expresiones y para hacer eso vamos a
usar esto mismo que acabamos de ver esta
otra propiedad de la siguiente forma
aunque hoy tenemos por aquí 27 elevado a
la potencia dos tercios eso por esta
propiedad es exactamente igual al 27
elevado a la un tercio y luego todo este
número elevado al cuadrado y lo mismo le
pasa a este 8 a la dos tercios esto es
exactamente igual a 8 elevado a la un
tercio y luego todo este número
elevado al cuadrado y ahora sí ya
podemos resolver cada una de estas cosas
porque para encontrar 27 a la un tercio
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar ese número que si lo
multiplicamos por sí mismo tres veces
nos da 27 y seguramente te viene a la
cabeza justo el número adecuado porque 3
por 3 por 3 o sea 3 multiplicado por sí
mismo
3 veces es igual a 3 por 3 9 por 3 27
entonces este número de aquí la raíz
cúbica de 27 es igual a 3 entonces este
numerador se convierte en 3 elevado al
cuadrado porque este 3 es igual a lo que
está dentro de este paréntesis y este
paréntesis lo estamos elevando al
cuadrado y bueno lo mismo pasa con el
denominador tenemos 8 elevado a la un
tercio
estamos buscando entonces la raíz cúbica
de 8 y ese número
pues tenemos que 2 x 2 x 2 es 8 entonces
8 elevado a la un tercio o sea lo que
está dentro de estos paréntesis es 12
pero estamos elevando a ocho a la un
tercios al cuadrado entonces por aquí
nos queda 2 al cuadrado y listo ya
terminamos de encontrar este número ok
3 al cuadrado es 9 y lo estamos
dividiendo entre 2 al cuadrado que es 4
muy bien
entonces ya viste si organizamos
nuestras ideas de una forma adecuada y
usamos las propiedades de los exponentes
estos números se vuelven super sencillos